I don't remember when I met Eric I don't
remember how I met Eric I just know he
was talking [ __ ] when I hear that's all
I know
the only thing I'm sure about is that
Eric Griffin talk [ __ ] I'm sure he
didn't like my shirt or he thought my
smirk was too big I feel like but most
of his sentences to me start within this
[ __ ] here he is one of the
plenty of people of them as a comedian
and as an actor just one of the funniest
people ever Jerrod Carmichael presents
ray Garcia
the next on the air Krypton me thank you
uh what's up everybody so weird show uh
guys are we doing a play or some [ __ ]
right now um so I had this first of all
I don't like that you can't just talk to
women on the street anymore like you
can't just be like hey how you doing oh
you look good you know I mean they got
the ass and titties out but I can't say
anything but they're like I'm dressed
like a horse for me I like hacen Diddy I
mean if the dude was rolling down the
street with a wheelbarrow full of
Twinkies I would be like yo where you
going with you thinking holla at me you
know cuz I like Twinkies but I'm not
saying I would trip the guy take two
Twinkies you know what I mean
I mean I got swinging I wouldn't do that
that would be inappropriate but you
don't know how difficult it is for guys
not to be creepy all right we're already
put in situations like like you can't
open your eyes during the massage you
know what I mean just immediately you
make eye contact with the pursues all of
a sudden you like okay this is [ __ ]
creepy I just which is a quit you know
but I guess you can't be like this
though is that that would be creepy I
remember I had this situation this is
what happened to me I was at this
restaurant I was Joan's on third anybody
ever been there but they got this like
like state like a weird seating where so
this girl is sitting like with her back
to me just like this right and some guy
tries to talk to her and it doesn't go
well so when he leaves I lean over how
did that go you know but that wasn't
even the creepy part you know so she
laughs actually and she turns her body
now she's this close to me she has on
some loose-fitting clothing and she's
one of these white girls it's just like
a I don't know she's [ __ ] saying you
know it's just that you know like in the
middle of the conversation her titty
popped out the whole titty popped out
and it was like this close where I could
have done like that like that was the
titty
but the titty was right there so now it
turned into and I didn't even hear what
she was saying cuz all I saw was titty
without hitting suck my titty titty
titty titty now I'm having a dilemma
cause like when a titty pops out in
public like every dude is like okay what
the [ __ ] do you do you go get in trouble
I can't erase this history in a man this
is really happening there's a titty out
so now I started saying I gotta do
something about this titty and I do I
tell her about the titty right ladies
would you want to know your titty
without of course right and then the
other thing to my mind I'm like if I
don't tell her about the titty and then
she looks down and sees the titty she's
gonna be like he was looking at my titty
so I make the snap judgment i'ma tell
her about this - yeah here's the thing
how you tell her about the titty is also
important because that could be creepy
too cuz I don't want to be like
yo teeny now that would have been
inappropriate so I just went excuse me
in the middle because she but I was like
I'm sorry
give me two grew up to but uh your
titties out but she went oh my god you
know she knew that [ __ ] titty
was that how do you not know your titty
is out like dudes I think is just never
out you know I mean that's strategic
will is so then you know you don't want
to be creepy I mean oh god give me such
a [ __ ] relative term like yeah first
of all let me ask the little ladies in
the crowd is it really that creepy that
I have Plan B in my medicine cabinet see
her yeah that's just being prepared it's
like having a defibrillator at your
house you don't use a defibrillator all
the time but if you having a heart
attack aren't you gonna be glad I'm like
Claire you know plan B is de pusi
defibrillator that's all that is I think
I'm pregnant
clear you know you dead baby out of
there
I'm trying to help women avoid the walk
of shame
okay like you think the walk of shame is
like heels in your hand
panties bunched up in your pocket trying
to find your car [ __ ] oh my God my phone
is dead you know that's not the walk of
shame the walk of shame is you walking
through Walgreens with that Plan B in
your hand
cuz there's nothing you can put in your
basket that's gonna distract people from
the plan B and they all try Oh peanut
butter gloves tide sponges Oh
printer ink [ __ ] pills just kidding
and you know what really pisses me out
though and I say I Plan B I just go the
unhappy creepy that's pee pee first of
all ya shouldn't even be in my medicine
cabinet
so that's creepy right there you know
he's supposed to [ __ ] see the plan B
in the medicine cabinet so you forgot
about that creepy part right there right
here's another creepy part too first of
all you forget why you need the plan B
in the first place you have elected to
raw dog with some dude oh you forgot
that part
- right forgot that part it's not like
you know the a leg or knee Weaver's
aliens and my dick opens up and then it
just comes out no you were riding some
dick and if you need to plan B you
probably one of these chicks fill me up
oh yeah oh my god does he know me you
know first of all what's creepier then
put a life inside me ruin our lives for
ass that's the creepy part I just feel
like like mother nature's like a evil
witch you know what I mean and she you
know how which cooks her spells in that
Black Cauldron
that's [ __ ] you know that man it's like
I eat in mother nature's like eggs and
then like a baby forms pretty magical
that's why I feel like I wish the moment
a chick got pregnant magic smoke came
out of [ __ ] just I'll be great at the
moment of consumption cuz we be like
[ __ ] I got this [ __ ] pregnant I got the
pregnancy smoke like I was a lot of
things I would change like like here's
how you get rid of racism no matter what
race you are your baby should be a
random race so it's funny it's funny cuz
white people always like put that one in
a suggestion box
let's circle back to that one
like whatever color the smoke is that's
what your baby would be if you got brown
smoke you got a hard worker pink smoke
yeah but we'd all secretly want a white
baby
that's what sucked oh so you see the
white smoke or the Pope you know I mean
I don't know which one you guys under
that the whites pay nevermind
all right what else is going on I uh I
got satellite radio in my car
anybody got satellite radio just curious
that's the best right cuz you got 300
stations what I love about satellite
radio is is like you can have 30,000
songs on your iPad but you're still
gonna look at it like this I mean
there's nothing on this but like if
you're in your car and your favorite
song should just come on you're gonna be
like oh hey jamming today like you just
heard it like 20 minutes ago but every
time it comes on you like ah you don't
do that with your iPod like if you saw
your song you wouldn't be like there's
my jab you know you don't do that with
other spontaneity is a weird mentality
like I have the matrix DVDs I love The
Matrix my favorite movies I have never
once put the DVD the DVD player
but if it comes on TNG I'm watching that
[ __ ] from beginning to end
so we're mentality it's the same reason
why men cheat on you ladies
cuz he's looking at you like an iPod and
I've done all this already
you got me spontaneous you got me like
we doing that tonight you get my clown
suit out to cleaners I don't I like
satellite radio especially in LA because
regular like I don't what's the last
time you listen to the FM it was that
time you turned your radio to FM you
[ __ ] can't in LA because you drive 10
miles and your favorite station and all
of a sudden it's like and then like you
know how stubborn you are when the
station starts [ __ ] up like you'll be
in your car just it's going it's gonna
clear up once we do the whole car is
sitting here like this you gonna change
your [ __ ] station you know you know
what station never does that it's always
on very dependable the Mexican station
you know Asia like where is this antenna
at the Mexican station
I mean you don't even have cell phone
reception and AMEX you've been attending
in Internet where the [ __ ] are these
Mexicans at that are listening in to
this station and there's like six of
them I for soccer games are on a
commercial it's [ __ ] crazy I like
sports talk radio that's my favorite
[ __ ] because you know I love this I like
they have fantasy football basketball I
got an MBA station I love that only
thing I like about sports talk it's a
lot of target marketing for men there's
two kinds of products I always play the
first one is like balding anybody bought
us my man's holding on for dear life
right there you with the mohawk that
comes like this I like at least turning
around dude when you have two sides neck
when there's two bald patches next to
the mohawk
you're [ __ ] bald he keeps looking
around I got us
you [ __ ] yeah it's not going
well for you for six times he went like
this
you don't feel that breeze on the side
of here
but I'm just saying Baldy medication
when that commercial comes on they don't
like you at all in that commercial
that's like the commercial comes on are
you tired of being an unfuckable mess
are you tired of your stupid bald head
scaring women and children do you ever
want to get [ __ ] again
again just like [ __ ] I have here and I
need to start taking these pills but the
worst one you know though the main one
is to dick pills there's a lot of dick
pills medication make it make it bigger
make it stronger make it black you know
it's like
lotta bad and these [ __ ] commercials
are really insensitive okay it's just
like a woman this is a real serious
radio commercial for the dick pills like
your car goes silent and then all of a
sudden you hear a woman go guys guys
size matter don't you want to please her
but now you in the car with your little
dick like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
Oh your girl's looking out the window
nice scenery [ __ ] leading a garage
[ __ ] but here's the thing there's a
lot of things aren't that are uncertain
in the world is there a god we really
don't know season finale of lost I still
don't know what happened my ethnicity is
a mystery are you guys like that Drake's
father you guys don't know who so
[ __ ] mystery but there's one thing
that every guy in this room knows with
100% certainty the dick pills don't work
if the dick pills worked we would know
this person's name they would have a
national holiday a Nobel Prize and every
due to be down to the knee cap we would
never I would we stop
women would be on panel show this is too
much
okay let's needs stop now my vagina is
destroyed its cavernous I have lockjaw
gay guys be like tell them girl
dick Carnival Cruise Lines just coming
is the gay dude Faridah woo are you
getting [ __ ] a lot you don't even have
to wipe it just fall down
absolution you got too much too much
golf media so weird title is it about
golf I'm just curious
alright would you obviously a big part
of it
say could you like you know talking a
lot
think that is my house attitude yeah
these are my drapes over here and I mean
you know my multimedia Center I put in
not all cribs right now you still had a
show shut the [ __ ] up I'm just serious
well I got I got the white girls over
here just kind of waiting is there a
rapper Lee trying to get pregnant um
what else am I gonna do you know I don't
know um all right is the last thing I
talk to you about I had to get my oil
change anybody get there I think my oil
changed all right
and I've decided that I'm only going to
a real mechanic from now on because you
ever go to like the quickie easy Jiffy
Lube II places and only reason why we go
there why because we [ __ ] cheat it's
cheap and you see the sign 1995 for the
oil change but you get a look at the
sign carefully because it says 1995
Monday Thursday before 9:00 a.m. and the
winter solstice you have to look at the
sign
look at the sign so I'm cheap I checked
the calendar is 855 I walked in yo let
me get to $19 change
I always hit you with this would you
like to use the good oil good are you
using bacon oil potatoes okay give me
the good oil now it's $65 for the
[ __ ] oil change right and they're not
even done you're in the waiting room
waiting for your car and then the
incomes of Spanish dude with the sales
pitch excuse me
is that your are you knock on inside
with me not call me inside look at the
computer this computer is not even
connected to the internet much less my
car what the [ __ ] are you looking at
then let they like to show you the car
to look like hey I'm not a mechanic
Javier what if I can you show me to [ __ ]
for just fix the [ __ ] man then then
they'll give you a piece of the car to
here if you feel that look at this field
now look at it it looks fine I'll put
this back in the car [ __ ] they're not
even they're not even done at that point
you now to hit you with this with the
sales pitch you know they hit you with
all the they don't know any on the
computer procedures you never even heard
of before you know what it means I okay
your carburetor it needs to be rotated
we have to shake it for carbonation
mind you have a belt it's missing a loop
of a plow we need to remove the belt you
have a cop in your cup hold it means flu
Apple use are you grave through you
mr. Pibb Fanta we have everything now
they hit you with the doomsday that's
how to get you to spin all your money ok
the doomsday he's looking at the
computer I've already said I just want
the or change man ok are you mad at me
miss your decision I cannot be
responsible for what happened oh my
goodness if you don't do this a baby
seal will die in the Arctic six hundred
dollars are spending this [ __ ] I got no
change I got a box of orange juice
I got a pap smear for some reason see
hey hey why are you big computers not me
it's a uni pop smear all right thank you
golf media for having where's our host
oh there you a makes this very
aggressive man
goth media